hello world welcome to this video
playing tiger Petrosian what's the name
of the sky my cool money ran okay yeah
so he doesn't want to have a bank oh it
seems I try anyway some kind of a bank
oh oh my god at the most stodgy line
possible we're okay why does of course
very solid so it's not something you can
review it with black okay let's take
this to open up something okay it's a
little bit quicker on the C file
actually which I should have thought of
a little bit that was stupid capture
what am I doing here that's really a
stupid move totally justifies his plane
anyway yeah it's a little bit awkward
now and that wasn't necessary at all now
he controls e4 and it's a little bit and
set a little bit quicker now I stupid
trade on d phone yeah I mean as it's so
not not so much going on because what's
the position is so entirely inoffensive
that you shouldn't be in trouble
regardless but it really wasn't good
oh yes some ideas I can go if Roy Fe
likes to gain some space nope but before
I is also an option try to make that
night on 86 look a little bit stupid at
least I was reasonably fast hmm ok ok I
don't really have a huge choice iam so
with a check now here and the six
potentially people call knight c6 might
happen ok I can do this
which again is not very exciting but
no okay reasonably no I was thinking you
would put taken hmm okay
I don't know if I really want to take
the night away hmm yeah maybe
it's still very bullish and 23 maybe he
wants to go for something like land
I'm wondering if 55 is a move here for
me or not like 85 is six putting
everything on light squares regarding
that is special i mean this Bishop isn't
looking all that grade 1 B 2 but he has
a for Bishop a three pretty much every
time every time I mean okay maybe be 5 a
6 I mean this is something that should
be helpful in any case okay so this is
this is something I have to do I don't
want to know it to OD 45 and here night
if four is actually interesting takes
takes me but I don't have any great
discovery so I'm going back
so f six or not I don't think so ya see
going 95 here I think I can go Quinn to
c7 and B 496 i have c voice as a square
yeah yeah quincy seven or not I don't
know I think I'll go for it a5 a4 would
be cool would be cool to get in
don't like that night in really don't
should I think I should put it on still
room try to get it to see 6g for I go at
five and stop and you for the expansion
yeah but I don't have to take it will be
at g5 mature ok so its aim for c4 or the
other 195 oh my god
it seems it tricked me somehow with this
stuff Knight e5 ng5 this is on check hmm
not good
Jax looks like time by my cash I'm sort
of made here now g-49 h6 is almost check
made but going back losses the hour so
if there is a mate I can it's just what
it is ninety-seven is no made but is
attacking a seven or an irritating
position right there a planner I'm
wondering is sexy I'm such an idiot and
ninety-seven is made oh my god I can't
believe I'm screwing this game up again
what the heck is happening meaning might
might win or tie more sunshine every FF
gifted so many points last games I'm
playing this whole time now I don't care
flight for fence on time geotech such an
idiot you start out with a completely ok
ending and then what happened here this
or maybe is that five really bad let the
engine hates the move I just cannot play
the host French position so i just
cannot i mean ok basically nothing
happened in this game never ever and
then we got to this ending tell me i
felt i should be reasonably ok ok got
this regrouped maybe I'm I mean I can't
I cannot believe that this should be
better for while I'm sorry I cannot
believe it with all the points here on
dark squares and the totally dead bishop
I mean how can this be better for wild I
must have screwed it up yeah okay here
g5 that was something that I definitely
had missed and now it's very awkward we
had my going now cannot move this night
never take him it wasn't really helping
me it was a mistake anyway but but here
I must be okay ready okay Bishop two
sexes winning more or less check yeah
okay that that is really winning oh my
god okay so I missed this one I was just
thinking to go to see for here with both
nights but yeah after this I'm toast
that's 95 and 95 and I cannot I cannot
really check cannot channel do it chat
probably doesn't made somewhere y an
idea three is checkmate that but if I go
back I mean this is just such as losing
anyway yeah so here Knight f3 I cannot
prevent this made it's pretty nice
actually yeah 96 many moves probably
will check yeah yeah some would ok again
but it was a wasn't was a some kind of
scam anyway check yeah if you hate one
on time there because I always complain
people play on time it's what it is I
just wanted the points I'm on a step
after scoring likes it one out of seven
or something I just want some points ok
guys thanks for watching